Alex ILO says the Schneider cut is near
DC Redemption arc
I am excited for this I hope so I'm
excited for this because I is
controversial apparently but I like DC
more than Marvel oh yes
spicy we went to I camera boat mug I see
yeah but this is probably long-standing
though it's not like the new movies have
swayed you you probably liked DC more
than Marvel for a long time absolutely
yeah yeah I like I make some ups they're
both you know it's like marbles in 9.5
and DC's at 10 you know what's the x-men
is that Marvel Marvel okay yeah yeah I
was a big x-men fan yeah it smells cool
one way was explained to me is that
Marvel DC is heroes trying to be like
people and Marvel is heroes people
trying to be heroes
interesting way to explain it yeah yeah
that makes sense but saw like Batman I
think what I like there's there's
there's issues with bad means it's like
super rich yeah I mean but he was
trained really really well
the contrast between him and say like
Iron Man in terms of their abilities is
that Iron Man isn't he's just an
arrogant drunk genius right Batman was
peak physical human condition and I and
I really like that there's you know that
what I really really liked about DC was
the fact that and Marvel does have these
heroes too especially the MCU most of
the MCU characters I believe don't have
any superpowers it's just technology
gadgets and stuff most of them yeah yeah
yeah but but some of them do have powers
in man it's just technology technology
and then Falcon technology iron man war
machine technology or machine yeah yeah
and then a couple may have powers but in
most the Marvel stuff I would read and
stuff out see growing up it's like they
all had powers but then you have DC and
I remember this I can remember exactly
what happened in one of the Justice
League cartoon episodes is probably in
the comic too where they're trying to
interrogate someone and he's laughing
and mocking them and then Batman walks
up and whispers to him and the guy
panics and just says I'll tell you
whatever you want to know and that was
really awesome that you know Batman
doesn't have powers but through hard
work perseverance training and
intelligence he was one of the he's like
the most powerful hero basically yeah
and one thing out one I know this is
gonna spark a debate among comic fans
but one of the ideas is that Batman can
defeat literally anyone with enough time
mm-hmm I'm sure there's an argument like
he'll never beat Galactus or something
but like they darksied like there's it's
no he will absolutely okay 100% yeah I
himself yep yeah he beat Superman okay
that's why Batman vs Superman night it
was it wasn't even just about the
Kryptonite but yes our mothers have the
same name that was isn't that what it
was that we were talking about cringy
moment the actual comic was great
it's like going older Batman beat
Superman to let him know like you're
vulnerable
yeah and they could have done that in
the movie I don't get it okay you guys
have seen Batman vs Man is a right there
this man here's the scene Batman is
wearing the armor and it's all messed up
and he finally just best Superman and he
takes the spear with kryptonite and then
he's about to finish him off and then
you know Lois comes in she's like and
then he's like got out of the way or
whatever and then he says you're lugging
him kill Martha and he goes why do you
say that name and he goes no our moms
have the same name
no and that like that changed everything
as a stupidest thing ever
I'll tell you what should have happened
Batman's entire arc in that movie was
basically that Superman was too powerful
and if he wanted to he could destroy
everything and no one could do a damn
thing about it that's what he says yeah
and so what should have happened is
right when he finishes off me he beat
Superman and he grabs a spear he should
have looked over to her man and said let
this be the day you never forget the day
I defeated you and then throw the spear
aside as I walk away and the whole point
was Bement isn't evil it is when it
kills her man he wants him to know he
isn't a god maybe the snyder cut maybe
did that maybe it's supposed to be
darker and different yes I'm excited for
this although that's that's not the same
right it's that's Batman versus super
Superman not the Justice League right
all right that was my remember Superman
Justice League they resurrect him but
that's the Snyder cut we're gonna what
Justice League yes Justice League okay
so the choices they made what do they
not have any fans making these movies
you know you know you're the secret is
though and it's Kevin Feige because he's
basically hit hit a home run on every
single what does he done MC moved all
the MCU movies all of them
oh all of them yeah yeah he's like the
main dude okay Captain Marvel I kind of
roll my eyes at
liked it it's a for me it's like they
stake they squeezed in too much
desperate I see what you're talking
about but I mean when I when I watched
it I was like guys this is good movie
yeah I liked it I don't know no there's
no stakes or powers are weird it's like
they were talking about how she was the
most powerful hero yeah and then even in
endgame it really really hurt the film
yeah that it's like it didn't make it
she didn't make sense than that when
when Thanos had but Sir uh-huh and then
she just like smirks I'm like oh come on
give me some stakes yeah don't just
whack me over the face with like we get
it she's super powerful and no one can
hurt her and then Thanos grabs the power
stone and then hits her with it and
that's finally I you know you know what
man they you make a character with no
flaws mm-hmm and that's the flaw an
arrogant narcissist overpowered just
spare me dude I do not want to see that
yeah I want to see them fix the DC movie
universe there yeah well it's a great
taco man to is it is super easy all you
got to do is just replace amber turd dun
dun boom you know what's crazy about
excited about that movie what's crazy
about the Aquaman movie is that actually
was good I really really liked it I
thought so too I like to the underwater
fights between him and what's the other
guys his brother or yeah or his half
brother the half brothers that it was
beautiful really cool he's epic yeah I
liked it but the scoring was just oh oh
the music yes
like when nah but when the the dudes in
the sinking submarine and his dad's
dying oh yeah that the music it just
came off as like like a parody of it
almost like it was I was like watching
SNL version of it was a little that felt
forced that whole scene and they just
did not even talking about the music
it was scene was just like why are you
trying to get like what's going on here
I think it was too slow of a death yeah
maybe it should have been faster it
should have been like at the last minute
his dad like like the torpedo hit him
and not like you know and just crushed
him normally or like when in the end of
Gardens of the galaxy - mm-hmm yondu
puts the spacesuit on
on Peter yeah and then saves him and
then he slowly dies and Peter's going
now that was awesome right what an epic
it should have it could have been
something like their sinking and then
the dad takes off his rest you know you
know his sons respirator fails and he
takes us off and gets to his kid and
then pulls the cord you know and then
air shoots on it he goes no he gets shot
up right that's nice dad they could've
done something like that but anyway
anyway that movie was good yeah it was
it was wasn't it that the timing is
weird though how like in Justice League
that the chronology is before Aquaman
riot but he goes into Aquaman well I
mean people liked it they like him I
like him music he's cool Jason Momoa
yeah he's a collector
I liked him in that you see I think the
the Warner Brothers stuff they were
trying to race to Avengers yeah
definitely and that's a problem they
should have done it don't stop trying it
maybe stop trying to be them did you do
your own thing people are gonna like it
they know what they should have done is
they should you have to build up to the
ensemble cast yeah okay just start with
it yeah yeah what were they thinking man
like the MCU was built up over a decade
that's true of introducing these movies
and then when did Iron Man one that was
the first one right it was 2008 2008
doesn't eight or nine Wow I think the
Hulk was like oh seven or something but
no the first Hulk right with Edward
Norton no no no this the first Hulk was
with Eric Bana oh and then and then and
then Marvel Studios took it over and
then did with Edward Norton right at the
end of that the general what's-his-face
meets with Tony Stark because they were
for that I think in the beginning they
weren't planning on doing this big MCU
yeah they were just Pro mowing the next
film right and it was one universe and
at the end of Iron Man
I think I think of Iron Man was at Thor
yeah they they found it and there's the
hammer right and then because it all
linked him together they were like now
right what DC should have done that you
know but what I think they tried doing
was they basically tried getting their
infinity war off before Marvel could
yeah because they thought that would be
better I guess because like Justice
League was the mother boxes and I'm like
right you should have done what Marvel
did yep
introduced all the characters and then a
movie and when they introduced
cyborgs they could introduce one of the
mother boxes and then not have this but
then not only that but when they did
Justice League that it was almost like
they're trying to do their Avengers
infinity war but instead of giving us
Darkseid they gave us Steppenwolf is
irrelevant you know what is it dark side
I thought it was dark seed dad I think
it's dark side Wow okay but it's just uh
I don't know what they were doing and
then the birds of prey men oh man it's
it's like it's like getting punched in
the gut over and over again because I
like DC so much more I really do I
really really like Justice League yeah I
like Marvel but I feel like Marvel is
too weird I like my suicide squad it was
okay but it wasn't Suicide Squad
it's I don't really know anything much
about Suicide Squad it's it's supposed
to be that the government wants black
ops right by using villains they can
disavow any association with whatever it
is they get caught doing pretty cool and
that's not what it was
Suicide Squad they just made a superhero
movie yeah but not only that it was like
a weird like our fault
like what's what's-her-face I'm
forgetting the lady's name I can't come
of my tongue I talking about
the woman who runs the Cadmus I can't
think of her name people gonna mention
in the comments now because I'm sure but
uh she brings on the the I'm totally
forgetting the movie the Cara Delevingne
woman is possessed by the like the mummy
the demon lady and then she goes rogue
and then the suicide squad stops her but
that's not what Suicide Squad was it
should have been some it could been very
simple like infiltrating a foreign
adversaries you know research facility
yeah
because it could have been something
like this this government is developing
a bio weapon go in and destroy it and
then well and then it could have been
like in the end one of them gets caught
and then and then you see like breaking
news and it was like you know you know
Harley Quinn was captured trying to
steal a bio weapon right right and but
what people don't realize are the
Quinn's plot or plan foiled by our
government like exactly the day and then
she actually ended up destroying you
know whatever they were doing or
something which would have been a great
segue into an actual Harley Quinn solo
movie but no what they tried doing
harley quinn i think they tried making
lady Deadpool mm-hmm everyone's saying
Amanda Waller's Amanda Waller yeah I
knew it thanks I was like they're all
gonna jump in jets the best but dude
it's man I I just the Justice League
cartoons are awesome I like Green
Lantern Batman Marvin I really liked
Green Lantern a lot Green Lantern is
cool and and what was I watching I was
watching one of the movies where a
hammer believe it was I just watched it
recently one of the animated Warner
Brothers ones why is it that the
animated Warner Brothers DC movies are
great can't you that's what I hear that
live what do you yeah I hear that
they're really good so some some
villains from the future view the Green
Lantern as fascists okay are like
militaristic you know okay interspatial
you know they they basically are like a
police force a military Marines yeah but
there's a lot of really cool things they
explore by anyway long story short you
get these these Warner brother animated
films on Amazon and they're awesome hmm
they're great I don't think I've seen
any of them why why do we end up with
this weird stuff this weird you know I
don't know it's the it's the social
justice people that are infiltrating
everywhere
well that's burden influencing I think I
mean I think it has something to do it's
becoming more prevalent you write it
that birds of prey was is a prime
example of that yes Justice League
wasn't social justice you okay it was
just just bad but it you know what it's
also the people that don't know the
actual comics they're they're not
Justice League fans Seuss Suicide Squad
fans they're not like oh man I grew up
watching Suicide Squad now I'm a part of
this movie let's let's really pay homage
to what it was let's do that that's not
what's happening they're like all right
we got these big actors Will Smith and
all these other people yeah let's make a
big epic movie yeah but what about
Suicide Squad I feel like what they're
doing is they're like what IP do we have
no like we could do Suicide Squad
awesome now how do we make it the
Avengers right it's like no no no no no
people really like Suicide Squad one
they want some of that how do you think
that Avengers money man they've made a
million dollars didn't it something like
that yeah I mean but Justice as you said
they built it up a
right if they just put Avengers out
there endgame with no nothing else it
wouldn't have been the same it would
have been really awful actually
oh yeah infinity Wars yeah is amazing
and yeah and game I liked but I really
does feel like endgame was just a like
are we hard we have to put this out now
no no it's an anthology episode like you
know you watch a show yeah and they just
do flashbacks the whole episode oh yeah
that's what it was and so it was ok but
like what I don't like about endgame is
that the villain is of their own
creation yeah they go back in time they
trigger some Thanos he comes to the
future and then fight someone I'm like
but then I was already dead that's kind
of dumb you know yeah infinity what was
amazing yeah that was it it feels like
DC is just like it's so mish-mashed
they're like okay we have Batman we have
Superman will do Batman vs Superman can
we make it like Marvel yes but darker
ooh yes oh I don't understand like the
explanation I gave you of how they could
have resolved that that's the way it was
supposed to be he has the sphere up to
Superman's neck then he throws it aside
and says you know never forget I
defeated you and that would have been
the end of it and then supermo would
have came to realizing he was defeated
so here's the thing in that movie when
Superman approaches Batman asking for
help about his mom mm-hmm he comes as an
arrogant dick you know and he walks up
and he's like if I wanted to kill you I
would and so Batman goes at him hardcore
that was fine and then Batman should
have won and then Superman should have
come to realized that he was defeated
but Batman didn't kill him yeah and then
he would have been like what you know
and then Batman
then it could have gone to regular
dialogue where he was like you've you've
acted with impunity for too long you are
not a god on this planet and then
Superman could have been like I'm sorry
yeah I need your help and then they
could have it could have been normal
instead it was like Martha
you know you know my favorite meme about
it was is that like I don't know there
was a cartoon or something but the joke
was they're fighting yeah and then all
of a sudden like it's at the point where
Batman's gonna beat him and then he's
like but he's like no don't kill me
because my mom Martha is in trouble and
then Batman goes your mom's name is
Martha - my mom's name is Martha dude
your
mom's name is Martha that's so cool you
want to be friends we'd like that's
right yeah that's it that's what it was
waiter yeah man so I don't know the
Schneider cut they're saying might be a
like a four-part miniseries that'd be
cool yeah because there's like four
hours yeah on ten long movie and they're
talking about having a lot of the
footage that never got used has to be
has to be like touched up and they got
to do the CGI no no that makes sense
yeah right because they never actually
used it maybe it will be good one thing
I don't really like about it is Wonder
Woman seems underpowered and Superman is
just no P I don't really remember it's
been a long time since I've seen that
movie like Wonder Woman is really strong
but it seems like the gap in power
between her and Superman is too great in
the movies yeah to me I don't know maybe
it maybe I'm wrong yeah and her movies
like she's a boss like she know her
power levels is say in between her
movies and Justice League okay I just
feel like she should be substantially
stronger okay I guess you know maybe
it's early on or whatever but then when
you have Superman coming in to save the
day he's just too powerful it's Superman
I know Superman Superman that that is an
issue horrible but they could still
write something into that where you know
when Steppenwolf comes and he he's like
a Kryptonian or whatever and he knows
Superman's there there could've been
reconnaissance he goes at something as
simple as like they could have showed a
scene where he's talking to Darkseid and
he's like earth has since gotten a
Kryptonian and you know it's a Yellow
Sun you know this means and then he goes
well we're gonna need reinforcements or
something or will need kryptonite that
has been for me it's dark seed it is
dark seed that's okay that's what people
are we're adding me oh there you go
thanks again general I'm just saying
words
anyway anyway if was if you weren't
Martha you weren't hip I'm hoping that
they can salvage this series but I have
no faith I remember out I think I came
over what movie I was leaving and I
walked out we're talking about it and
there was some like you know fat
neckbeard kind of guy okay and they were
talking about it too and then I
mentioned I like DC more and then he
stopped just like no how does it feel
thank you very much forming mimamsa feel
when someone else does it to you
what know me that wrong my love feel my
like of Batman vs Cyclops
is incorrect yeah no that's that's
that's totally different
that's like they're both still having in
in terms of literature Batman and any
other Marvel hero are of equal merit
it just it's depending on what you what
you see in these heroes that you think
you like more than something else right
right right
so I I like I think Batman's awesome I
do and I and I like I like how a lot of
the movies have have handled Batman
actually think Ben Affleck did a great
job I think he did yeah actually he did
an alright job as Ben and I have to
agree
henry cavill was great as Superman -
yeah I'm actually bummed he stopped
because he's actually he made me like
Superman in those films better because
he did a good job of it it's a shame he
left because DC was crumbling you know
that Superman used to have the ability
to fire miniature Superman's from his
hand
miniature Superman's yeah little
versions of himself that's cute because
I guess apparently like early on
Superman didn't have any like defined
powers okay so I was reading something
that said he was actually a lot we need
Superman he couldn't fly you know and
then they introduced a bunch of weird
random powers and it wasn't later on
till they did like ultimately like here
are his powers mm-hmm
but I was also there was a viral post on
reddit recently that said kryptonite was
introduced because the voice actor for
Superman in the early cartoon wanted to
date wanted want to take one on vacation
mm-hmm so they're like okay Superman's
sick it's a kryptonite and so that way
they could have the voice actor like you
know take a day off or for like a week
on vacation or something that's funny
yeah it's funny how a lot of a lot of
these things work with like the business
side of things has to make a change so
it has to incorporate some kind of story
arc change you know to accommodate a
reduction in staff publishing time voice
actors yeah anyway we'll see how it will
see how it plays out thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you